how much of your experience may be your
faulty or whatever right play a role
into the opinions that you form about
other players and also your perception
of this generation versus how whatever
it was like for you when you were in the
MBA yeah do you think and I don't I
don't I want to be clear on this I don't
think that you did anything wrong here I
think that both people were right in how
they felt with the Klay Thompson
situation
yeah I was disappointed in clay because
hold on for a second I mean I was
disappointed in clay because I went back
and looked at what I said okay
clay was the best two-way player in
basketball for a long time
and what I said was
he's still a good player he's never
going to be that guy again for two
reasons for three reasons h
Achilles and ACL
no player
gets better when they get older that's
that just doesn't happen but you every
player declines first and foremost as
they get older but you factor in an
Achilles and an ACL
you I said and like I said and we've
talked about this I said I didn't say
the guy was a bomb I said he's never
gonna be that guy again I was caught off
guard because I went back and look I
said clay still a heck of a player but
he's never going to be that best two
guard in the NBA that he was for a long
time because of age Achilles and ACL
and I was disappointed that he
overreacted because he 100 overreacted
because I said he is still a good player
but his days of being the best two guard
in the NBA because I'm gonna tell you
what happened that night because I've
been there
Devin Booker was kicking his ass
and when you get older
and you like
this guy's kicking my ass there's
nothing I can do about it
because that was really hard for me
when I got older because I'm like this
dude can't play and he's kicking my ass
that happens to every great player
but then you could tell clay was
frustrated because he started talking
about the four rings which nobody can
ever take them four rings and he's one
of the best players ever but that night
Devin Booker was kicking his ass and
there was nothing he can do about it and
I saw the frustration and that's how I
came out I said you know uh Clay's gonna
have to understand he's got four Champs
he's a great great player but
because of AIDS Achilles ACL
there's nothing he can do about Devin
Booker at this stage of his career but
you know that like
and the reason this is interesting to me
is because it's like both things in
essence could be true right like you can
think that clay won't be the same player
but he can also have his feelings hurt
by you saying that and so calling it an
overreaction I think is more that was
his feeling about what it is you said
but what you said you're entitled to I
don't I don't think you did anything
wrong with that but I think that it's
hard to say that things we say aren't
personal when you're talking about
something that is so personal to someone
does that mean 100 it's a hundred
percent but if he actually listened to
what I said I said Clay's one of the
clay because you know there's a thing
that annoys me about these players today
when I said
for five to seven years he was the best
two guard in the NBA offensive on
defense he never picked up the phone and
said damn Charles that's a really nice
compliment
but this is what I actually hate about
this generation
uh and this is honest I'm not gonna lie
to you ever
I can say nine great things about these
dudes
they call me on the one thing when I
call them out that's the thing that
annoys me the most uh like I say clay
who I like a lot as a person never
called me and said man Charles somebody
who knows basketball calling me the best
two guard offensive defensively in the
league for five to seven years man
that's a really nice compliment he never
called me he got my number but the one
thing where I was actually making a
basketball point a true basketball point
I might please I was like yo man
you're over 30.
you have the ACL you have an Achilles
those three things don't go great
together I'd say I didn't call him a
bomb I see still a heck of a player but
that one night I I saw I saw myself a
little bit like man getting older is no
joke see because that's the one thing
that sucks about sports
no when you get older you're still
playing against a little 20 year old kid
who first of all he's dominant rocks but
he can run and jump like a mofo and like
my last two years I was brutal in
Houston I couldn't play dead and
I had two good years in Houston in the
last two it was so frustrating because
I'm like these dudes can't even play
these dudes can't even play and there's
nothing I can do about it because
father time is undefeated it's going to
get everybody